- Today we're going to be talking about
the single greatest time management tip
I ever received about law school.
Outlined from day one.
So stick around and get
an edge in law school.
(melodious instrumental music)
It's hard to overstate just how important
your outline is in law school.
It's going to be your
primary studying device.
It's how you distill all of
your notes and your cases
and your commercial outlines
into a usable format,
specifically tailored just for you.
But the kicker is that
the process of distilling
everything takes time,
and it takes way longer than you think.
And time is the single, greatest
equalizer in law school.
Everyone has the same amount.
And the students who get A's
are the ones that focus
on what's important
and they cut out the time wasters.
In other words, they focus on the stuff
that actually helps on the final exam.
Now a good outline is necessary
but it's not sufficient
to crush your final.
The point of an outline
is to study from it,
to organize things in a logical way
so that you can study the crap
out of the things that
are in your outline.
It's a means to an end, not an end itself.
Now this might seem like an
obvious point but I mention it
because more than half
of my law school friends
believe that it was better to wait
until the end of a semester
to start their outline,
because they felt that they've studied
by making the outline itself.
They thought that the simple
act of making their outline
was enough to study for their exam.
But this is so wrong.
Now sure the building
of your outline helps,
but it's only the first step.
Imagine if you were
preparing for a chess match
by reading books about
the history of chess
and you waited until the
week before the match
to actually memorize how
the chess pieces move.
It would be much better to
have memorized that stuff
way ahead of time and
practice before your match,
and the same in law school.
Better to have your outline done
months before your final exam
instead of wasting your
precious study time
compiling your outline.
Then as finals approached,
you can practice by
applying the information
that you already put in your outline.
What most students don't
understand about their outline
is that more is not better.
There's an old phrase
that, "If I had more time,
"I would have written a shorter letter."
The same is true for outlines.
It takes time to distill
all of that information
for a particular class
and to get it into a short usable form.
Ideally, believe it or not,
I would say the best outline
is less than 20 pages.
Some people try to fit
everything their professor
has ever said in a class
into their outline.
But this is the exact opposite
of what you should do.
The longer your outline is,
the harder it is to use.
And law school exams are
all about the application.
Your outline is your tool bag.
You want it organized, you want it clean,
and you only want the tools
that are going to help you
for the job at hand in your tool bag.
For example, a good craftsman
could probably build a table
with just three tools.
Sure he might be able to make it faster
or better with more tools,
but it's better to have three tools
that you know like the back of your hand
than to have a hundred
tools that you don't.
And it's the same way
with law school outlines.
Much better to know a
smaller outline intimately
than a longer outline only superficially.
But distilling all of that
information takes time.
And I'm not going to lie, it's hard work.
Make no mistake, distilling
all of the information
from your class, in commercial
outlines and from your peers,
into a short concise summary
is one of the hardest
things about law school,
but it's also invaluable.
So do yourself a favor
and start from week one.
The most common objection I hear is,
"But I can't start my outline
because I need context.
"I need to wait until I see
"how the whole class fits together
"before I start distilling things down."
Well I have bad news for you.
You will never have the
whole context for a class.
And you'll always have
an excuse to put it off.
But you have to act and
just start doing it.
Nassim Taleb, author of
The Black Swan wrote.
"Understanding how to act
"under conditions of
incomplete information
"is the highest and most
urgent human pursuit."
Amen to that.
Make your outline starting
week one and then revised it.
You can always go back,
and you'll probably find that
very little of what you write
during the first week of class
will be used on the final.
You can always go back and revise it.
You'll understand more as
the semester progresses.
But it is far easier to revise as you go
than it is to start from scratch
just a week before finals.
Do what the startups do.
Build a beta version and
then iterate from there.
Here's what I suggest.
Monday through Friday
during a regular semester,
consider it your job to
listen to the professor,
take good notes, read your
commercial supplements,
and try and understand as much
as you can about the class.
And then over the weekend,
distill all of that
information into an outline.
No more than one page per class per week.
If you can do that, by the
time the finals come around,
you'll be done with your outline
and you'll already be
crushing your practice exams.
It just takes a little work every week.
It's a marathon not a sprint.
So start early, be consistent,
and you'll crush finals
with a kick ass outline
that you started writing
back in the first week of the semester.
Oh, and by the way, if you
want to get better grades
on your next law school
final, check this out.
We've put together a free e-book
called the Ultimate Guide To
Crushing Law School Finals.
Just click the link below to download.
It will show you exactly how
to prepare for your next final,
including how to plan, how to outline,
and how to study for your
next final, just click below.
Also if you like this video,
please subscribe to our channel.
We come out with new videos
on how to crush law school all the time.
So thanks from everyone
here at Legal Eagle.
(upbeat instrumental music)